buenas tardes pues fue una larga
procesión de hecho fue mucho más larga
de lo que se esperaba aquí sobre el
rollo de la arteria principal del casco
antiguo de edimburgo esta procesión en
la que se vio este féretro envuelto en
el rollo de estándar de escocia y que
bueno pues se era esperado por miles de
personas aquí en la capital escocesa que
llegaron desde muy tempranas horas de la
mañana para tener un buen lugar y ver
pues el paso de todo este cortejo
fúnebre muchísimo silencio algo muy
solemne muchísimo respeto y emoción
también en los ojos de las personas que
estaban aquí en edimburgo y luego pues
en esta ceremonia que duró cerca de una
hora con muchas representantes de la
política escocesa por supuesto la
familia real algunas lecturas entre
ellas fue el himno el salmo 23 era uno
de los favoritos de la reina isabel y
que además fue interpretado también el
día de su boda a la príncipe felipe en
1947 ya la salida de esta ceremonia pues
vimos al rey carlos iii a la reina
consorte camila que saludaron a la
público el automóvil uno algunos algunos
aplausos un poco más de emoción y hasta
hace unos pocos minutos ya deja
abandonaron la catedral las últimas
personas que participaron en esta
ceremonia natalie ahora que se prevé
para mañana
bueno mañana es el transporte de los
despojos mortales de la reina isabel a
londres ahora hoy en la tarde y durante
espacio ya de 24 horas las personas que
quieran si tienen el brazalete podrán
ingresar a la catedral para darle el
último adiós a su reino y luego de esto
esta velada también en donde estará la
familia real durante un tiempo esta
noche aquí en la catedral pues ya será
el traslado del que les ha hablado esto
será en la tarde de mañana sobre las
cinco de la tarde -hora local- pues el
féretro será llevado al aeropuerto de
edimburgo en donde volarán a bordo de un
avión de la royal air force y será la
princesa anna la encargada de acompañar
el féretro hasta londres una llegada
aproximadamente sobre las siete de la
tarde -hora local- la de londres y luego
pues el féretro que será trasladado al
palacio de buckingham